with the increase in the need of ip
addresses we need proper information or
identification for each ip address that
is ipv4 version and ipv6 version which
is the best ip address for a requirement
to do so this video will help us to
identify it
hi guys and welcome to yet another
trusting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today's video
for today's video we will understand
what is ipv4
continuing with what is ipv6 addresses
and in the end we will look at
differences between ipv4 and ipv6
let's take a look at the first heading
that is ipv4 addresses
the first version of an ip address to be
developed was based on 32-bit binary
format that counts roughly around 2 to
the power 32 bits of total ip addresses
in ipv4 format
which was sufficient at the initial
phase of network requirement
but is somewhat lacking according to the
current advancement in the network
technology
the addresses in this ip ranges from 0
to 225 in terms of zeros and ones
with four octets where each of them is
separated by a period
this is an example for an ipv4 ip
address
where the first three parts represent
the network id
and the last part represents the host id
using the ipv4 address as our reference
we can identify ipv4 addresses from ipv6
addresses
now let's move on to the next topic that
is ip classes
ip classes are designed to allow easy
and efficient assignment of ip addresses
to a network
depending on class size we have five
different ip classes in a network that
are named as a b c and d
for the first part we have class a
that accommodates network with a large
number of network host
where the first bit in the octet is
always zero with number value ranging
from 0 to 127
then we have class p
which can fulfill the requirement for a
modded number of network host
the lead bit is 1 and 0
and network id ranges from 128 to 191.
then we have class c which can allocate
an ip address for low number of network
host where the first three bits of the
network id is 1 1 and 0
ranging from 192 to 223
so the above three classes that is class
a b and c
we can easily identify and assign
addresses to a network host
moving on we have class d
where it is used for multicasting
that means it is used to send multiple
signals at the same time from a single
host
for example using video streaming
where the lead bit is
1 1 1 and 0 with network id ranges from
224 to 239
and then we have class e
where the ip bits for this is reserved
for research purpose only
where the ip addresses ranges from 240
to 255.
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for ipv4 version addresses
where the first is
the memory required for storing ipv4
version addresses in a system is very
low
then we have ipp4 version addresses
apply connectionless protocol for
sharing data
and providing the best effort in
delivery
moving on we have stacking option for
ipv4 addresses
that means
in ipv4 version it allows to create a
multiple network over a single host
which allows different hosts to connect
to it
moving on we have
ipv4 version addresses being the
earliest ip designed are applicable to
most of the network devices and system
for connecting to the internet so it is
supported by
many devices
then we have ipv6 addresses let's take a
look
with the increase in the need for an ip
address the ipv4 version addresses are
somewhat unable to complete the
requirements of the network host
so the need for ipv4 version auros
which is based on 128 bit address size
which is sufficient for a very long time
that is approximately 320 under civilian
ip addresses in version 6.
this type of ipp version is designed of
4 hexadecimal digit and 8 sets with each
block containing 16 bits separated by a
colon
moving on let's take a look at some of
the features for ipv6 version addresses
where the first is
ipv version 6 addresses provides an
integrated security protocol for the
network that is internet protocol
security
ipsec
then we have it allows its application
to extend in various services according
to the need of the network
it also allows address configuration
through stateful that uses dhcp server
for network settings and stateless that
applies auto configuration settings
ipv6 addresses also allows some methods
to convert ipp 4 addresses to ipv6
addresses
which is according to the requirement of
the host or the network
moving on let's take a look at the
differences between ipv4 version
addresses and ipv6 version addresses
this heading would allow us to choose a
best ip address that we can
decide for a network
let's take a look at the first
difference that is address and
performance
in accordance to the address size ipv4
version is composed of 32-bit address
length and is the fourth version of the
internet protocol
for ipv6 we have
the address size is 128 bit long and is
the latest version of the internet
protocol
the second difference is on the basis of
address field type
ipv6 addresses are based on numeric data
with four fields each separated by a
period
whereas for ipv6 addresses are based on
alphanumeric type data with eight fields
each separated by a colon
the next difference is based on address
configuration
in ipv4 version addresses a manual
setting for the network is required
along with the dhcp configuration
settings
whereas in case of ipv6 version
addresses the network setting is based
in accordance to the system's
requirement and it also supports auto
configuration setting for the system
moving on we have
the number of addresses in each ip
in case of ipv4 the total number of
addresses are nearly 4 billion addresses
whereas in case of ipv6 version we have
320 undecillion addresses
now let's take up a quiz to understand
what we did so far
and the question is
identify the correct form of ipv4
version address in the given options
and the options are
you can give your answers in the comment
section below
let's move on to the next difference
that is address security and functioning
ipb4 version addresses do not provide
any security function for the network
whereas in case of ipv6 addresses
integrated internet security protocol
that is ipsec is responsible for the
security of the network
the next difference is
encryption and authentication settings
ipv4 version does not provide any
encryption or authentication services
for the network
ipv6 addresses do provide
mandatory encryption and authentication
services for its addresses
moving on we have address routing and
performance
ipv4 version follows routing protocol
that has rip for network configuration
and is preferred over ipv6 version
and in case of ipv6
it does not follow any routing protocols
and it uses static roots for network
functioning
now that we are completed with the
differences between ipv6 and ipv4 we can
easily identify the ip address we want
to choose for our network
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here